i have to talk about your skincare line
first of all i kind of wanted to bring
this because i just wanted to show
everybody like what it looks like when
you're lucky enough to be the recipient
of this care package first of all you
get this amazing magazine is zine if you
will
i mean look at how beautiful this is
and this line is so
gorgeous
i know look at this
thank
you it's it's stunning thank you it's
been a
labor of love so this is the outset and
we just launched like a minute ago um
and uh it's been a project i've been
working on for five years and
now it's here and it took a long time
and uh you know it's
this skincare is based on my own
skin care um you know i had problem skin
for a very very long time and did
whatever you could you know took every
like use every mask and prescription
cream and you know peel and whatever and
um you know it's felt like when i used
things that were very gentle and i i
would have this regimen of like you know
prepping my cleansing my skin prepping
my skin and moisturizing it and just
like putting the nutrients back in like
my skin would be its happiest and then i
would use all that other stuff and so
this line is meant to be you know it's
we call it the white t-shirt of skincare
you can like pair it with all whatever
else you're doing and it's not that
that's sexy yeah oh yeah thanks um you
know it's not gonna react with anything
else that you're using we've eliminated
like 2700
harmful ingredients um it's vegan it's
not allergy free it's gluten-free it's
clean skin care
and it feels so good um
and it's like it's so moisturizing it's
like the whole story is all about
moisture um hydration moisture and
hydration and you know it's like we
i didn't want to just be making skin
care for myself so we when we went out
there and you know did our consumer
research we found that actually the
majority of people are
are genuinely like over 90 of people are
happy with their skin they just want to
maintain the skin quality that they have
and and so you know it really is meant
to be used by
as many
people as as as possible when did you
have problem skin because i swear i mean
i could like grow i crush out on you so
hard like when i'm so sexy with the best
skin no thank you but no oh stop
oh my god i'm i'm literally up close and
personal and i'm like it's you just have
the most beautiful skin i've been using
the outset secretly for a year
didn't you uh test it on colin too i did
well when we were first coming up with
the product lines he yeah he did he was
like the eye cream he that eye cream is
because i never used eye cream now i use
eye cream but like you have an eye cream
yeah i have an eye cream this one i need
an eye cream right now yeah
i really do oh and i create i
i also i love that we're sitting down
that's fine um i also um you know i've
been telling like people have been
telling me for years i should be using
an eye cream
and then when i met actually colin is
the first partner i've ever had that um
used an eye cream i was like oh okay oh
cause he um has products and stuff he
has like a few products i guess i mean
he's not like overly it's not like i
went in there and it looked like a
sephora you know but
um he's open to a product yeah i didn't
have a lot of people in my you know at
the time we were doing all this like it
was like fedexing over covid yeah like
you know we were doing all this testing
ourselves like my partner co-founding
partner kate foster and i were you know
in our product developer and then the
few people we had around it was like her
husband was using the eye cream colin
was using the eye cream you know if
anybody came over i was like want an eye
cream
um you've got eyes
uh yeah and i'm looking at your eyes and
i want this cream yeah it's a good it's
a good eye cream we have had a lot of um
a lot of compliments with this eye cream
eye cream it's an important thing so
excited that you have a skincare line
because skin care to me is my absolute
weapon and arsenal it's my tools
definitely so i am so excited i
cannot wait to keep using these i trust
you implicitly i trust you i trust you i
appreciate that it's true
[Music]